The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TADGE DRYJA: And that brings
us to today's lecture,
which is also something I
was not as familiar with.
So sort of a disclaimer--
I might have gotten
little things wrong,
or it might not
be quite as clear.
But do ask questions.
So if it's stuff like Lightning
Network or Discreet Log
Contracts, well, for
me-- that's sort of easy,
because I know it really well.
This stuff is things
I've known about,
but I've never really
went as into the details.
So it's a little
bit like, OK, figure
it out well enough to explain
it rather than just well enough
to understand how it works.
So the basic idea is you want
to hide the output amounts.
So we saw last week how
looking at output amounts
can deanonymize and let you
link a lot of different things.
And so we'll look
at how to do that.
How do we hide output amounts?
And so we'll talk
about commitments.
So first, we'll talk about the
reasons why and how to do it.
Then we'll talk about the
definition of commitments.
What is a commitment
in cryptography?
And then we'll talk about
Pedersen commitments,
and then we'll talk
about range proofs
and put it together
to get what's
called "confidential
transactions," which
is a vaguely confidential
transaction-- it just means
the output amounts are secret.
So interrupt with any questions
at any point of the way
if something's not clear.
So coinjoin-- last
time we talked
about combining transactions
with other people
where you have your input--
they have their input.
You have your output--
they have their output.
And if you shuffle the ordering
of the inputs and outputs,
it might not be clear
who's sending what where.
You're aggregating it,
and in the process,
you're losing information,
because no one
gets to see the border
lines between-- hey,
this is one transaction-- this
is another transaction-- it's
all in the same transaction,
so you can't really tell.
But one issue-- and
a really big issue--
was that the output
amounts can often reveal
who's sending what where.
So in this example--
well, maybe I
don't know who's A,
who's B, who's C,
who's D-- these all
look like uniformly, random
addresses or pubkeys.
But if I see an
input with 10 coins--
an input with 2 coins,
and then an output
with 2 coins, and an
output with 10 coins--
well, there's probably
something like this going on.
Why else would you do this?
If you were trying to
send 2 coins somewhere,
why even involve
this 10-coin input?
Why not just say 2 coins to
2 coins, and you're done?
So if the goal is to obscure
the transaction graph
and have better anonymity
because no one can
tell what's going where--
well, this doesn't really work.
I think it's going like that.
And then I showed that
there is a way to do it,
whereas if you have 2 to
8, then the 8 is obviously
from the person with 10.
But the 2 different 2 coin
outputs are unlinkable.
So that helps, but
it's not great.
And then for things like the
aggregate signatures, maybe
you can get people to aggregate
their transactions together
because it's
cheaper and smaller.
But in general, they'll have
totally different input sizes,
totally different output
sizes, and it won't really
give you any anonymity.
And it won't give
you any privacy,
and it hurts fungibility.
So how can we do this?
Wouldn't it be great if we
could hide the output amounts?
That would be really cool.
So instead of having
it like this--
it's just you don't see
how many coins there are.
Why don't we just delete
the output amounts entirely?
Why even that saves 8 bytes.
So we can't just delete it.
So what does this mean?
This would be
really cool, though,
if we could somehow obscure
this so that no one can
tell what the amounts are.
And, I guess,
initially, so they're
going to be some transition
since Bitcoin wasn't built
with this from the get-go.
At some point, there will
be a transaction where
you can see the input
amounts, but then you
can't see the output amounts.
But then you can have bounds
and say, well, neither of these
can be more than 12.
And then as it goes forward, and
if the transaction graph gets
bigger, those bounds
start getting really wide
because you're like, well,
this might have been 11,
and this might have been 1,
and then the next transaction
if it's mixed in with a bunch
of things that have a pretty
wide range, you
have to take the max
and min of all those things.
And, the min is
always going to be 0,
so it works pretty well
even with this transaction.
You could also think
of a new system
where either you start
with obscured amounts,
or the first mining
amounts are non-obscured,
and then you mix them.
Anyway, so this seems like it'd
be really useful because it
would allow you to combine
transactions and get
better privacy.
Also, just really
nice in general,
even if you're not trying to
combine with anyone else--
it's really cool
that people can't
see how much money you have.
If people can see how
many coins you have,
they can try to
charge you more--
they can try to rob you--
there's all sorts of reasons
why people don't usually
say how much money
they're carrying around,
or how much they make, or how--
things like that.
People are sensitive
about pricing information,
and some of it's societal
taboo, but also a lot of it's
like I don't want people to
know how much money I have.
And I think there's--
I've read recently
like Uber doing
this thing where
they like, oh, you're
rich-- we're going
to charge you more.
And people don't like that.
It has been historically doable.
Companies segment
things, but often the way
they do it is they're
like, OK, well,
we're going to make first-class
seats and then economy seats.
And the first class
seats don't take up
the space of 10 economy seats--
they take up the space of maybe
2, but they cost like 10x.
And the idea is, well,
if you're rich-- we're
going to charge you more.
You can have the
fancy stuff, and we're
going to make more
profit off of that.
That's more OK, I guess,
but if it's just-- no,
you're getting the same economy
seat, but we know you're rich,
so we're going to
charge you more--
that-- I don't know.
And we're getting
into that future
where there's enough data that
a lot of companies can do this.
And some people,
probably myself included,
is like wait, no,
I don't like that.
I like the way it was before
where companies didn't really
know that much about me.
So this is an effort to try
to keep things obscured--
try to keep the customer a bit
more anonymous with respect
to merchants so that they
don't have as much information
to charge more.
And then-- rob you--
that's maybe more
Bitcoin-specific where like--
yeah, I mean if
you're walking around
in an area that's
sort of high-crime
with a bunch of money hanging
out of your pocket-- that's
a bad idea.
The internet is sort of a
high-crime area, especially,
with respect to Bitcoin.
And it's really easy to
see how much people have.
And so people-- the
hackers know who to target,
especially if it's
like an exchange--
they're pretty clear--
OK, this exchange
has tons of money.
So it might not
help the exchanges
that much-- it obviously has
a lot of money, but anyway.
So this would be
really cool to do.
I think people sort of agree--
this would be really cool.
This is a nice thing to have.
And it also helps with privacy.
You're trying to
make it hard to link
different outputs to each
other or link the outputs
to a specific person.
And hiding the amounts
makes them really hard
to distinguish.
So if you don't
know the amounts,
they become completely
uniform where this
is a completely random address.
I have no idea how
many coins there are.
I have very little
way to distinguish
between these outputs.
I can try to trace the
graph and say, OK, well,
this came from here--
this came from here,
but they all look the same.
So I've got this big graph
with no real information
other than the links
between the notes,
which is still information.
But it's much harder to
tell what's going on.
So we're sold-- how do we do it?
First, we need to define--
what exactly are
we trying to do?
What are we hiding from whom?
Who knows what and
when kind of thing?
So the long-term
state of the system--
no one can see any--
no one can see it
in the amounts.
A has signed a
signature from key A--
a signature from key B--
some amount of coins.
You don't see it. you
don't see any of this.
So that's the long-term state.
But wait, people
receiving the payments
should probably know how much
they're receiving, right?
And they should probably
know how much they have.
If you don't know how much
money you're getting--
that's not a very
useful payment system.
People sending should--
they should also know
how much money they're sending.
If the amount can be completely
determined by the receiver--
that's also not a
good payment system.
I'm just going to
take lots of money.
So we can have two views.
We can say, OK, only the sender
and receiver know the amounts.
How about that-- where from
the network's point of view--
so if I'm just the third party
looking at this transaction--
I don't see any of the amounts.
I just see there's no--
I have no idea how many
coins are being sent.
But from the sender's
view, the sender
says, OK, I know I
have 2 coins here.
7 coins-- I changed it from
2 and 10 on that line--
2 coins here, 7 coins here.
And I'm sending 7 coins
here and 2 coins there.
So the sender knows
the whole thing
because they're the ones
creating this transaction.
And then maybe the receiver
doesn't see everything.
Maybe the sender can prove to
the receiver a single amount
but hide everything else.
That would be ideal.
So the receiver only sees,
oh, I'm receiving 2 coins,
but I don't know.
If I know this, then
I can figure out
what these are, or at
least the sum of them.
But if I don't know
any of these things--
I don't know how much the
person sending me money has.
I just know, oh, I got 2 coins.
Cool, that's what I wanted.
But I don't learn anything
about their inputs
or their other outputs
within the transaction.
So that would be ideal
if we can do that.
So what we want is a
system where network
doesn't see any of the amounts.
The sender presumably
sees all of it.
Now, there could be cases
where there's multiple senders,
and there are two people working
together to make a transaction,
and maybe we don't see
each other's inputs,
but we'll keep it simple for now
where there's a single sender.
And then the receiver only
sees their own output.
So that would be a
really powerful system.
Then the receiver
would only know
they're getting the
right amount and not
learn anything else
about the sender's coins.
So we might want to--
like I was saying,
you might want to
hide per output.
So if you have a--
if it's a global--
either you see everything or you
see-- sorry-- you see nothing,
or you see everything--
that's still pretty good.
That's still better
than what we have
when everyone sees
everything, but it is better
if you can hide the rest
of these three things
from the receiver.
So any ideas?
Some kind of encryption?
Hide the amounts
so the only people
with the right private
key can see the numbers?
So, I don't think I've even
talked about encryption ever
in this class, because there is
no encryption in blockchains.
[LAUGHS] Which is
something you--
if you read something
about blockchain
and you're like
blockchain is encrypted.
And you're like no,
no-- they don't know
what they're talking about.
So I haven't defined encryption.
But encryption is-- generally,
you have some kind of private
key--
you take a clear text,
you apply-- you do some--
so like I had with signatures,
you have a set of functions.
So encryption is-- you've got
some encryption function which
takes a key and a message
and outputs a ciphertext.
And then you've got some kind
of decryption function, which
takes off in the same
key or something and then
the ciphertext and
outputs the same message.
And this is symmetric
encryption because you're
using the same key.
You can also have
asymmetric encryption
where this could
be a public key,
and this could be a private key.
So in order to decrypt,
you need the private key,
but in order to encrypt, you
only need someone's public key.
So, in practice, all
the things that people--
in practice, you
usually stage it,
so you have an asymmetric
algorithm to agree on a key,
and then you just use
the symmetric encryption
and decryption where the keys
are the same because it's
way faster.
So you can do this operation
on the order of hundreds
of megabytes a second, whereas
the asymmetric ones are slow--
it's sort of like signing.
Maybe I'll go into it later.
But if you understand all
the signing and stuff,
it's not too bad.
But so maybe you
could say, OK, well,
there's some kind of private
key that the sender creates--
encrypts the amounts, and then
they put the encrypted amounts
in the transaction, and they
reveal the key to the receiver.
And, potentially, you
could have different keys
for each amount--
that would work.
Any problems with that idea?
You can encrypt everything.
Yeah, you know?
AUDIENCE: You would need to send
over a public key or something
so they can decrypt it.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, oh, OK, so
that is a sort of problem--
it's a limit.
But that limit will carry
forward to the stuff we do.
So you're going to have to--
right now, in Bitcoin, you
can find someone's address,
send them the
coins-- you're good.
With this system,
there will be more
interactivity between
sender and receiver.
So that's not great,
but not a deal breaker.
So we will need to do that.
Other problem?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: A key
for every amount.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] because
of the fact that there can be
a lot of different
ways to split up the--
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah,
it could get bigger.
And the actual
solution gets big.
So that's not great either.
But the one that
really screws it up.
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do the nodes
verify the transaction?
TADGE DRYJA: So the nodes don't
verify the transaction at all
because they can't see anything.
Well, I can do that.
Well, how about I just make
70 coins and 2,000 coins?
I can make as many
coins as I want.
No one can see anything because
the network just sees nothing--
have no idea how many
coins are being sent.
But I'd be like,
hey, hey, I'm making
more coins all over the place.
[LAUGHS] And this doesn't work.
Because if I can
send coins to myself
and multiply them
indefinitely, and it's hidden--
so to some extent,
you're like well,
maybe the network doesn't care.
Because well, I'm making them,
but they're only my own coins.
But if the network
doesn't see anything,
it's easy to create the coins.
And if those coins
are later used,
I can't tell if they
were made up or not.
So if I'm accepting--
so if I see this, and someone's
like, hey, here's 2,000 coins--
I'm like dude, you're
making them up.
You can't write extra
zeros on $100 bill
and be like here you go.
This is-- come on.
No one's going to
accept these later.
I won't even know.
Did you even have 7?
Does this 7 coins
come from something
where you did the same
kind of thing before?
So, basically, if we do
that where we completely
obscure the amounts
from the network
and from all third
parties, then anytime I'm
going to accept this,
I'm going to have
to enforce the rules myself.
And then retroactively enforce
the rules for all transactions
beforehand to make sure
nothing like this happened.
So we could do that.
It's all obscured.
The third-party-- the
network doesn't see anything.
And it's up to the
participants themselves
to say, well, if you're
going to send me coins--
since I know if I'm sending
it to someone later,
I'm going to have to
provide some kind of proof
that this kind of
nonsense didn't happen.
I'm also going to
need proof that all
of the ancestor
transactions that
led to these 2 and 7 coins--
I'm going to need those amounts.
And, so, yeah, you
could maybe do that.
You could provide the decryption
keys for all previous amounts.
But that basically gets you
back to where we are right now--
not quite, but pretty close.
Either you allow
people to create coins,
or you basically are revealing
close to all previous amounts
eventually to everyone.
Because as that transaction
graph gets bigger and bigger,
I'm going to start having all
these thousands and thousands
of ancestor transactions
that I'm going
to have to require proof for.
I'm going to require all
those decryption keys
to make sure nothing
like this happened.
And then eventually, all
the people receiving money
will be able to see
everything-- well, not
quite everything, but a lot.
So it's like well,
third-parties--
the miners or maybe people
who are just looking
at the blockchain who aren't
really receiving any funds--
maybe it's hidden from them.
But once you start
using the system,
you're going to basically
be able to see everything.
So that's not great.
And it would also
be really annoying
because then when you
have to receive coins,
you have to go back through
thousands of transactions
to make sure that didn't happen.
So we need to prevent
coin creation while still
keeping the amount secret.
This is a tricky problem--
any general ideas here?
So wouldn't it be
cool if we could
do this where the network
sees there's w coins here,
there's x coins here,
and there's y coins here,
there's z coins here?
And then we have a proof--
w plus x equals y plus
z, without telling you
what w, x, y, and z are.
Cool.
Let's do it.
Any ideas?
[LAUGHS]
So this seems like
this would work.
This would do it in that if
we can reveal like say, hey,
the person d--
z is 2.
Cool.
So I got 2 coins.
And they can also verify that
these amounts are correct.
And then if you're--
you could either keep this
proof only to the receiver,
but then you'd
have to give proofs
about all the
previous transactions,
or you can just, say no--
the whole network enforces
these groups.
This is now a consensus
rule where if you want--
even if it's not
your transaction,
it might be a parent of
your transaction someday.
So you have to verify it.
If you're going to
accept the block--
verify these proofs
for every transaction.
So that would work.
AUDIENCE: So that's essentially
a minor deal, right?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, a miner, or--
the miners would do it
and also the full nodes.
If you're running a node--
well, I'm not receiving
anything here,
but I still need to make sure
this is a valid transaction
in order to accept it.
AUDIENCE: Isn't that a problem
then, because what if a miner
is in that transaction?
TADGE DRYJA: If the
miner's receive--
the miners D in
receiving this coin?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TADGE DRYJA: Then they'll know--
then they'll both
get the proof, which
is sort of redundant for them.
And they'll also get
the actual amount-- z.
So they'll know this is 2.
So that miner would know
more, but that's OK.
I guess other miners wouldn't--
or other nodes wouldn't.
So if you're participating,
you'll potentially know more.
But the idea is
third-parties see a proof
and don't see the amounts.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So SPV
will have no way
of knowing if a transaction was
valid until it was [INAUDIBLE]??
TADGE DRYJA: They already know.
So SPV, while it's
already have no idea
how many coins are
coming in on the inputs
because they don't
have a UTXO set.
And the coin-- so
if you see an input,
you see it's pointing
to some txid.
I don't know how
many coins there are.
I would have to--
you could provide a
proof to an SPV wallet
that, hey, there were--
I can give you that
previous transaction,
and you can see how many coins,
but then what about the one
before that?
So, generally, SPV
wallets can't enforce
that amounts are correct
or verify signatures,
because they don't know
enough about these inputs,
whereas full nodes--
when you tell me to
input 0, I know how much.
I know what keys--
things like that.
So SPV can't well--
no there's maybe some
way to make the SPV
have it so that SPV proofs
are compatible with this.
But it's-- you already
don't have that.
So I don't think
there's much idea--
there's much much
research into how
to make this SPV compatible.
But yeah, it's a good question.
Other basic ideas?
So how do we do this?
[LAUGHS] So this
will take a little--
the actual way to do this will
take the rest of the class.
Because there's a lot of
things where that seems like
it'll work, and it's
like oh, no, it doesn't.
And this is sort of replaying
the ideas from several years
of people trying to do this.
So how will we do this?
So there's an idea
called commitments.
And the simplest form
of a commitment is you
commit to some value--
you ouput it-- call it c--
and then you reveal the value
and then someone can verify.
Well, given c and the
value you just revealed,
is that a correct commitment?
So I'm committing
to the value 2.
I'm outputting something c
and then revealing it was 2.
And let me throw this
into my function.
2 and c-- do those match?
Oh, it's true-- we're good.
And then there's certain
properties you'd want.
You don't want people to--
I think I have
slides about that.
So the hash function
is a commitment.
I can say the hash of 5
is 68 empty-- whatever.
And then I commit
to 68 something.
I publish this,
and I tell everyone
I'm committing to something.
I'm not going to tell you what
I'm committing to exactly,
but here's this 68fde0b7--
some long hash output.
And then I reveal
days later the thing
I was committing
to-- that was 5.
And then everyone can check.
Let me throw 5 into
my hash function.
Oh, yeah, it was this.
True.
So that's a commitment scheme.
It is binding.
So there's binding and
hiding, and there's
different properties
of commitment schemes.
So this we could say is
a computationally binding
commitment scheme.
Once I've committed
to this, I'm not
going to be able to
find another number.
So I'm not going to be
able to say, oh, it was 6
And then get the
same commitment out.
So I'm not going to-- so in
practice, this is really long.
This is a shot 2 output.
I didn't want to
write the whole thing,
but it goes to
here, or two lines.
So the idea is I can't find
another number, especially
exactly the number I want.
But I can't find any other
number that will get me
to that same hash output.
That's a collision, and I'm
going to have to try it.
Wait, so for a specific number,
I'd have to try 2 to the 256.
For any collision, I only
have to do 2 the 128.
But still, both of those
are really big numbers.
I can't do it.
So it's computationally binding.
If I had some
amazing computer that
could perform an
infinite calculation,
I could find a collision.
So there's the distinction
between computationally
and information theoretically.
Information
theoretically is stronger
where even if I had the
most powerful computer,
I still couldn't do this,
whereas binding, in this case,
it's computationally binding--
computationally is good enough.
Everything in
Bitcoin is already--
everything in all these
systems is already
basically computational.
There are some schemes, which
are not computationally bound.
So one of the parts here--
and the Pedersen commitments
are not computationally--
and things like severe
secret sharing and a couple
other things where this is not
dependent on processing power.
Even if you have infinite
processing power,
you just can't figure
out what the values are,
which is cooler, but
it's nice to have.
It's not a requirement
for our systems.
So this is binding.
Any ideas of what this is
not-- why this would not
be a good commitment scheme?
You want to commit to a value
and then later reveal it.
You don't want the
person who's committing
to be able to change
their commitment.
What else might you want that
this probably doesn't provide?
AUDIENCE: Do you
need some way to be
able to hash the commitment?
TADGE DRYJA: Yep.
So you want to be
able to do fancy stuff
with the commitments.
Before we even get there,
that's in 5 or 6 slides--
before we even get
there, this doesn't
satisfy something else we want.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: All but like 5
is such a common number?
TADGE DRYJA: This
is easy to guess.
So if I'm committing
to a number,
I'm going to commit to
the number of pizzas
I'm ordering at my party.
And everyone's
wondering how many
pieces are you going to order?
I try things.
It's binding, but
it's not hiding.
So verifier can easily guess
and check the committed value.
So for i equals 0.
Just keep trying
different i's and see
if the hash matches 68fd even.
And this will take
very little time
because 5 is going to
happen pretty quick.
And then everyone will know
he's ordering five pizzas--
sounds like a decent
party, but not
really worth going out
of my way to go to.
If it was fffff pizzas--
that would be something else.
So solution-- pretty
straightforward solution.
Add a blinding factor.
So we're going to call that,
r I guess, r is random.
So r is b8bc7579.
And now I'm going to take the
hash of 5 and concatenate r,
and now this is
a different hash.
And now to reveal what
I was committing to--
you reveal both 5 and r.
And you need to tell people what
order you're doing things in.
The system needs
to be predefined.
When you're committing,
you also have
to commit to the algorithms
or have pre-agreed
upon algorithms,
because otherwise, you
could do something--
no, I committed to r.
5 was my blinding factor.
You need to have protocols set
up beforehand, which you never
know, that could be some--
if you say, I'm committing.
Here's this value.
How are you committing?
What hash functions?
What are you doing?
But that's obvious.
It might not be
super obvious, so you
have to be careful on that.
So this is now blinding.
And it's hidden, and
it's still binding.
You can't change it to 6.
I think that's the
next slide, wait.
So you can't change this to 6
and change to a different r.
I mean, you could,
but you'd still
have to do a lot of computation.
And this is now--
some things get easier.
So before if you really wanted
to reveal that it was 6,
you basically can.
Because there's a single
output for 6, and it just
doesn't match this.
So there's not-- if you have
a single chosen value that you
want to reveal that's not the
one that you committed to--
you're basically stopped.
There's no way to get around
it even computationally.
With this-- that's not true.
It's like I really
want to reveal 6,
I can come up with a different
r such that the hash of 6
and our prime is that.
And then that's
now computational--
slight distinction.
It's still binding
computationally.
But before, chosen
values may not have been.
So that's, I guess,
the difference.
It's computationally
binding for any value.
But for a specific
value, it might be--
not information
theoretic, but you
can't do it, because the hash
function doesn't help you
there.
So what else do we want to do?
You're saying we need more.
We want to be able to prove
things about the commitments.
So we need some kind of
homomorphic commitments.
And we've seen the
homomorphic properties
of these elliptic curve
points, which are really nice--
where you can add
private keys or add
scalars, and that's the same as
adding these points on a curve.
So let's try that.
We want something like this.
We want a-- commit
to x, commit to y,
and get these
commitments-- a and b.
And then we want to reveal
z, which is x plus y.
And then we want
the verify function
that's put z in and a
and b-- either a plus b
or a and b separately
and return true.
So we don't want to
reveal x and y separately.
We will reveal the
sum of x plus y.
And then we will reveal--
and then we'll have the
commitments themselves.
So since these are
the same operators,
it'd be cool if that worked.
This is what we want.
So that's not that bad.
But we also want all those
properties where it's hiding,
and it's binding and
things like that.
So what should we try?
First idea is-- this
would be useful.
How can we build this?
We want to-- we can reveal
sums without revealing
individual parts that
we've committed to.
So probably the first
idea is let's just use
private keys and public keys.
Let's use a times g--
that kind of thing.
Oh, oh-- I forgot the joke--
was going to say, gee,
how can we build this? g--
it's g.
You want a commitment to act.
You want a commitment to y.
You want to reveal
z is x plus y.
So what if you did this?
You said, I'm going to
make a point on the curve--
x, which is just my
value x times g--
point on the curve y, which
is my value y times g.
This does have that
homomorphic property.
But is this binding?
It is.
I can't come up with a different
x that gets me to that point.
So multiplying by
the generator point
is a hash function in
that you're not going
to be able to find collisions.
So you can't find two
different private keys that
give you the same public key.
Sometimes you can.
[LAUGHS] So I don't want--
in this specific
case, this is binding.
There's a bunch of
asterisks that's there.
I probably shouldn't.
It gets complicated.
There are some curves
where it's not.
And some systems where it's not.
And there have been
problems in currencies
where people assume
that this is the case--
I think in Monero.
But, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you draw
an example of curve?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
So they-- the curve for
Bitcoin, I think it's y q?
No, y squared equals
x cubed plus or minus?
Minus 7, I think.
That's it.
It looks sort of like this.
It's symmetric,
which that isn't.
I think I had it
in an earlier one.
And then the x-axis is like
this is the origin-ish.
And then the idea is you
have points and you can--
the sum is if you
have the sum there
it's going to be here,
except it's here.
So the idea is 3.
Any line you draw more or less
will intersect at 3 points
unless it intersects
at a tangent,
or if it's straight
up, then you say
it intersects at the
point at infinity.
But any random line
you make will probably
intersect in 3 different points.
And so then if this
is a, b, and c,
we define a plus
b plus c to be 0.
So then we would define
b plus c to be here--
negative a.
And the negation is you
flip it over the x-axis.
So I talked about this
a little bit before.
But the idea is you've still
got this nice property where you
pick a point on here-- g--
everyone picks a random
point, and it's a generator.
Because if you keep adding.
So here's g-- sorry--
and take the tangent--
find this is 2g.
Take the tangent here--
maybe it goes here to 3g.
Take the tangent here-- or
no, that would be 4g-- sorry--
this would be 8g.
So you can keep adding the
g, and you'll eventually
cover the entire curve
and get back to g.
So that's why it's
sort of a generator
because it lets you get to
every point by just multiplying.
So the nice property here is
if you have some number x times
g, and some number y times g--
you can also do x plus y times
g, and that equals xg plus yg.
So you can add the points.
And that's the same
as adding the scalars
before you multiply by g.
And that's what basically
we use for everything.
And then the idea is
you can't go back.
Given a point, let's
say we call this big X--
given a point-- big X,
which is little x times g--
you can't figure out what x is.
So you can't divide by a point.
You can't say oh,
given x, I want
to do x divided by
g, which is little x.
I can't divide some stuff.
I can multiply by
repeatedly adding.
But division is not defined.
So this is binding,
but I don't want to--
there's asterisks that's there.
But it's not blinded.
So same problem is the
raw hash-based commitment
where if I want to commit to
the number 5, and 5 times g,
and that's my point that I'm
going to use for my commitment.
Same problem-- 4-loop
will pretty quickly
show you that was 5.
How about-- this seems
like a good idea.
I should say it in
the less obviously--
it's not a good idea way.
[LAUGHS]
So why don't we add
a blinding factor?
What would the problem be here?
I want to commit to 5.
I'm going to add
some random number r
and then multiply that
sum by g, and then
when I want to reveal that
I was committed to 5--
I reveal 5 and r.
AUDIENCE: You don't know
which one is [INAUDIBLE]??
TADGE DRYJA: No, but I
can say, look, the first--
well, yeah, the problem is
addition is easy to break.
When I committed to 5 plus
r, I revealed 5 and r,
but it's not binding.
I can find r prime, which
is 5 plus r minus 6.
And then 6 plus that r prime
is going to be 6 plus 5
plus r minus 6.
I can compute whatever
r prime I want
and whatever number I
want to reveal later.
So this isn't binding anymore.
I'm now adding a
random thing in,
and I'm committing to the
sum of the thing I want
and a random thing.
But it's not binding because
that addition, I can play with.
So how about this?
I'll hash 5 and
concatenate r and then
multiply that
hashed output by g.
Maybe, but then it's
no longer homomorphic--
then I can't add.
So if I have the hash of
5 and r1 times g and then
the hash of 7 and r 2 times g--
I can't add these anymore
And then have the 5s
and 7s add up to 12--
it won't work.
Because now it's a hash.
And I've just got
these hashes adding,
and you don't really
get any meaning there.
So that doesn't work either.
So we're stuck.
Then the way you do it
is totally non-obvious.
And introducing g's
fraternal twin-- h.
[LAUGHS] You make another
point on the curve,
and you call it h, which
is the letter after g.
It's another generator
point distinct from g.
So you pick one--
here's h.
You also need to make
sure that nobody knows
n such that n times g equals h.
That n might exist,
but you want to be sure
that no one knows
what it is because you
know how to move between g and
h, then that'll break this.
But if you take two random
points, g was randomly chosen,
and you chose a random h,
this shouldn't be possible.
That would be breaking
the discreet log problem.
So I shouldn't be able to
compute h divided by g--
you shouldn't be
able to compute that.
And so I think in a lot of
cases, they'll define h as--
take the hash of g's
x-coordinate and then assign
that to the x-coordinate for h--
something like that.
So it looks pretty random--
should be able to find it.
So we've got another
arbitrary point on the curve
that we're going to start
using for multiplying things.
And so this is basically
a Pedersen commitment,
which sounds involved
and it gets involved,
but really it's not.
At its core, it's not too bad.
It's saying we're going
to have a blinding
factor in the actual
value we're committing to.
And so now I'm multiplying
the blinding factor
by g and the actual value by h.
And I'm just adding
those two up.
So you know how we can do that?
If my actual value is 5, I
take 5h by taking the tangent--
getting 2h-- take the
tangent again-- getting 4h,
and then adding 4h and h by
drawing the line between them--
I'll get 5h.
And then I'll also
get r. r's going
to be some giant random thing.
R's not going to be like 5. r's
going to be a 256-bit random
number, and that will
obscure what h was--
sorry. what v was because
I added them together.
So this is binding
unless I know the ratio.
Unless I know h over g,
or g over h-- whatever--
same thing--
I can't come up
with another r and v
pair that gets me back to x.
So I can try.
There is one.
There's probably bazillions of--
if I could find a
different r, I could then
reveal that v was
8 instead of 7.
But I can't find that r,
because I need to know some way
to get between g and h--
some factor n where
n times g equals h.
If I don't know that,
I can't do this.
It is binding.
It's also hiding.
So you might
successfully guess--
I might commit vehicles 5--
do some random number
r times g plus 5h,
and you might guess correctly.
But this should have
been g-- oops-- sorry.
This is g.
But if I have some really
long, random number times g,
it's also an x, and you're not
going to be able to guess that.
So this is also hiding.
And it's homomorphic.
So x is r1g plus v1h.
y is r2g plus v2h.
And what if I want to prove
that z is value 1 plus value 2
without revealing
them individually?
Can you see how I could do that?
I can reveal both
r's individually.
Well, no, sorry-- I cannot
reveal both r's individually
because then you might be
able to figure out the values.
But I can reveal the sum of
the r's and the sum of the v's.
So I'm going to define
a point z, which
is point x plus point y.
And that's just going to be
the sum of the r values--
the sum of those
random values times
g plus the sum of
the actual values
I've committed to times h.
And then I reveal the sums.
I reveal this--
I reveal that.
And then the verifier can
do the math themselves.
It's a little hard.
I'm revealing r and v,
which is equal to this.
But I'm not revealing
these separately.
I only reveal the sums.
And then the
verifier can check--
is this r they gave times g
plus this v they gave times
h equal to these two
points added together?
And if it is, they've
proven the sum.
So, for example, it's binding,
hiding, and homomorphic.
So this would allow
us to make proofs.
Binding, hiding, homomorphic--
you reveal the sum of the r's.
You reveal the sum of the v's--
it works.
So basically now instead of
coin amounts, which are 8-byte--
they're in 64s--
I just provide
elliptic curve points,
which are 33 bytes,
so it's a bit bigger--
not a huge deal.
I can put another
20-something bytes
in my outputs-- no big deal.
And then I provide a proof by
revealing these sums each time.
So I prove that w plus
x equals y plus z.
And everyone can see this
little w amount of coins--
there's actually y coins.
There's actually x coins.
There's actually z coins.
And there's a blinding factor
that all the participants
have to keep track of.
So the receiver's views--
they learn their own v and r.
When someone sends,
they would have
to tell the receiver,
hey, here's r4.
The sender makes up r4.
And they can just compute--
let's make a random r3.
And then compute r4 such that
r4 plus r3 equals r1 plus r2.
They need to make sure that
the randomnesses add up,
which is easy because
they're regular scalars,
and the sender has full
control over r3 and r4.
So, basically, make random ones
until you get to the last one.
And then make the last
one such that they all
add up to the right number.
And then the sender can say,
here's your r4 and here's 2.
You're getting 2 coins.
And the receiver gets
those two numbers and says,
I can see that this
transaction commits to z--
a point.
And you gave me an r and a v
that when I do the operation--
I get z.
So I know that
successfully, you've
revealed that these
are two coins.
And I can use these
values later when
I want to send my own coins.
So this works, but
there's more problems.
[LAUGHS] Any idea what
the next big problem is?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If there
are only two outputs,
and then c's r4 and d4--
they could be able to
[INAUDIBLE] r3 and d3, right?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
But that's OK.
I mean, there's no
way around that.
If there's only one input--
or wait-- if there's
only two outputs,
so if the receiver
learns these, they
will be able to
distinguish-- if you
know the total amount of inputs,
and there's only one other.
You can just subtract
and figure it out.
So there's all sorts of things.
If there's only one
output, that person
knows it's the sum
of all the inputs.
AUDIENCE: You don't
know-- in this case,
you don't know the
total input, right?
TADGE DRYJA: Right.
In this case, they don't have
to reveal to you the v's-- they
just have to reveal that
2 plus y equals w plus x.
So you don't have to
learn their input amounts.
If there's only one output,
then you learn if this is 2,
these must have added up to 2.
But I don't learn exactly which.
So this is useful.
There's still a big problem.
r1 plus r2 is r3 plus r4-- you
can prove w plus x equals y
plus c--
it works.
It's great.
AUDIENCE: Do nodes only mean
the bigger transaction--
to know that the inputs
you put [INAUDIBLE]??
TADGE DRYJA: Yep.
nodes can just compute these
numbers, and they're good.
So one thing you could do here--
OK, wait.
So there's one thing that
you can do to break it.
But it's not a big deal.
And then there's another
thing-- you need a break that's
a really big deal.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Since
you're proving sums,
is it that you can have a higher
likelihood of proving something
that doesn't--
like that wasn't actually true?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah,
but how exactly?
So one thing you could do is--
I think, I said--
so, basically, you can verify
it and put in outputs--
add up all the points--
make sure they're equal.
You reveal r and v to
the person receiving.
And you don't want to forget r.
r is now a private key.
If you forget r--
you're stuck.
You can't prove
anything anymore.
You can make invalid
outputs, which
are just points with
no known r and v.
But nobody should accept those.
So you can do this where--
I have no idea what--
there is no commitment here.
Maybe these have
valid commitments,
but this is a point,
which is w plus x minus y.
And there's no known r values
or v values for these things.
And from the network's point of
view, this will still be valid.
The networks are saying, well,
w plus x equals y plus z--
we're good.
But then anyone accepting
that transaction--
you're not going to be able
to give them an r value.
And so they're not going to
say this is actual money.
So this is possible, but
it's not a huge problem
because you can
destroy your own money.
You can already do that in
a million different ways
in Bitcoin.
But if you send to it
to an output amount that
doesn't have an actual r and
v value-- that doesn't have
a valid Pedersen
commitment-- those coins
can essentially be
destroyed because no one's
going to be able to figure
out r's and stuff for here.
So that's one issue--
not a big issue.
Just don't do that.
Don't ruin your own money.
Make sure you always
have valid commitments.
And when you're
accepting payments always
make sure that you're given the
values and the random blinding
factors.
So that's one little risk
but not the big problem.
Anyone have an idea
about the big problem?
So as a hint--
all of these things, and I
haven't written it because it
gets really redundant-- all of
these things are like mod p,
which is some giant prime
number that's 2 to 56 minus 17,
or it's not--
in the curve, ed25509 it's
2 to the 255 minus 19.
So that's an easy
one to remember.
So that's why they
call it curve 22519.
In bitcoin, it's 2 to the
256 minus some numbers that
are not too huge.
So since all of these
things are modulo--
some big prime number--
what's a potential problem here?
It's a big problem
or in some ways
the opposite of a big problem.
Not a small problem.
[LAUGHS] The opposite of a
big problem but not small--
big negative problem.
[LAUGHS]
You can basically commit
to negative values.
So I send negative 99 coins
here, positive 108 coins here--
the numbers all work out.
So you don't have negative.
Usually, if you're
doing mod-some integer,
you don't think
of it as negative,
but you can think
of being almost
right at the top of
that modulo range
as being equivalent
to being a negative 1.
So if you say, I'm going
to have p minus 1--
that's some huge number
that's within the very
allowable range.
But it also will
let you treat it
as a negative 1 for
operations like addition
and multiplication.
So this would work,
and you can calculate
what negative 99 is-- that's
just going to be p minus 99,
or minus 100.
I always am off by 1
when I do these things.
[LAUGHS] Wait, is it 100?
Anyway, so you can calculate--
it's not really minus 99--
it's some big number
that's going to be 32-bytes
long-- that's modulo.
Modulo p doesn't change, but
it's equivalent to minus 99.
So that if I do add
these to this huge number
plus this other small number,
it loops over that modulo
and then gets back to--
what, 9.
So this plus this is going
to be 9 even though this
is some really long number.
This plus-- this is going to be
nine, and then it all adds up.
And then I've got this either
negative or implausibly
large value that I've committed
to, but I can just ignore that.
I can get rid of that.
That negative output
will be hidden.
No one will see that I've
got this negative 99 here--
then I can toss it and
end up with a whole bunch
of negative values
that are anti-coins
and a whole bunch
of more new coins.
And later on, I can prove
I've got valid proofs--
all these w plus x equals y plus
z proofs worked the whole time.
Shoot-- [LAUGHS] so we're stuck.
We need more than a proof
that the sums are equal--
was working really well.
But just a proof that
the sums are equal
is not enough because
we're modulo--
this big prime number.
And so you can make
these negations.
We also need a proof that
they're non-negative,
and not just not negative,
because that negative 99 is
essentially p minus 99,
which is some huge--
it's 2 to the 256 minus 99-ish.
So it's not just that
they're non-negative--
we have to prove that
they're reasonably sized--
that they're fairly small.
So if you could prove this
number is non-negative,
and it's less than 2 to the 64--
that would be cool.
How can we prove something
about the number itself
without revealing it?
So now this is an
even trickier problem,
because, before, we
wanted to prove a sum.
We wanted to prove
that z equals x plus y.
I don't want to tell
you what x plus y is,
but I'll tell you what z is.
That was proving a relation
between these numbers.
This is just proving
something about that number
itself individually.
We have to prove
individual numbers--
ranges.
So we have to say, this to 2h--
there's a 2h in there, and I
can't show you it, because I'm
just committing a w.
But I want to somehow
show you that the v here--
which should happen to
be 2, although I'm not
going to tell you--
the v there is within
a small range--
without telling you what it is--
without revealing it-- tricky.
So what you can try to do
is sign with the points.
Somehow, this is
what'll get us there.
The idea of we've got these
Pedersen commitments--
we've got these
points on a curve--
those are public keys.
That's how we used to
usually think of them.
Can we sign?
We know the private keys.
We know r1.
We know 2.
Can we make signatures
somehow and somehow use
that to reveal some information
about h but not too much?
So the signature equation--
I didn't really review
as much, but we've talked
about this a couple times.
Come up with a random value k--
take the hash of k
times g and the message
to be signed times
your private key--
that's your signature s.
The problem is x.
Your value that you've
got committed to here--
it's r2g plus 7h.
What's your private key here?
Well, it's our 2 plus 7.
But, no, because you know
the private scaler's here.
But there's 2 points
involved in this key.
So you can't make a signature.
Generally, signatures
are with respect
to a single generator point.
The way to verify this is
to multiply both sides by g.
s times g should be k times
g minus the hash of k times
g, message times 8 times g which
is a public key-- that works.
But now you've got h in here.
So we're stuck.
We could try to define another
signature thing with both h
and g, but that doesn't work.
But what we can show, which
is kind of interesting, well,
what if v is 0?
Then x is r2 times g plus
0h, which is just r2 times g.
This is nothing.
There is no h here.
And that means my private
key's going to be r2.
Well, now I can sign--
now I can re-sign with
respect to g with this point
x that I've committed to
because the value is zero.
The value-- the thing that
I'm multiplying by h is 0.
So it'll work for
a signature system.
The same regular old
signature equation
that we use, I can sign a
message with key "big X."
And so this is a
proof of a 0 value--
I'll sign with my own key.
So if x is some random blinding
factor times g plus 0 times h--
where v, the value you're
committing to is 0--
well, that means that
the signature is just--
so, the question is,
what message do you sign?
Well, maybe sign the message
which is the pubkey itself.
You don't need to sign a
message but throw that in there.
And then this will work.
And someone can say, hey,
here's a signature from key x.
And the signature is arbitrary.
It can be a signature
of any message you want.
But the fact that they are
able to produce a signature
reveals to you that v is 0.
So that's cool.
It's not that cool, right?
Because, well, I just
revealed my value,
and it revealed to be 0.
But I did it
without revealing r.
So that is cool, right?
I could do it by saying, hey,
here's my r and v values--
multiply them and add them
up to see that it gets
to the point I committed to.
But I can now prove that--
I can prove something about
v without revealing anything
about r.
Before-- we were saying, the way
you reveal these commitments is
you reveal the blinding
factor, and you
reveal the value itself.
Well, now I can keep the
blinding factor secret
and reveal a little bit
of information about v.
This works, and you can't
sign if h is non-zero.
You're not going to be able to--
you're not going to be able to
calculate any valid signature
unless v is--
ah.
V is non-zero.
Sorry.
So you can also do this
with a proof of v equals 1.
Again, sign your own key.
So you define x prime
to be just x minus h.
And then you can
say, well, look,
I'm going to prove
to you that v is 1,
and the way I do that is take
the point I've committed to x,
subtract h from it, and I'll
provide a signature
on that new point.
Well, this should be v. I
can't do that unless v is 1.
So if I have this,
and then I subtract h,
then I get back to r times g.
I can now provide a
signature just using r--
it'll work.
So what does this get us?
We can prove that v is 0,
or we can prove that v is 1,
or, really, we can prove
that v is anything.
Just subtract a whole bunch
of h's and subtract 7,000 h
and now provide a signature.
And that proves
that v was 7,000.
But wait, we just revealed
v, so what's the point?
Did that really get us anywhere?
If we can make a signature
that reveals the value
we've committed to with
hiding the rest of the stuff--
is that useful?
If it's kind of cool, but
what can we do with this?
Any ideas?
So there's another part that I
didn't have time to introduce,
but maybe will at some point,
and you can read about it.
It's really cool.
Ring signatures--
a ring signature
is similar to a
normal signature.
You've got key pairs.
You've got sign,
verify, but there's
a set of public keys during
the signing and verification
process.
So the basic idea
is, I sign a message
with one of the public keys,
but I don't tell you which one.
And you verify that, yep,
there was a signature here.
I'm not quite sure
who signed it.
There's possibly three
or four different people
who may have signed it.
But I know one of them
signed it but not which.
So, basically, it's the
key-generation step--
same as before.
You have some keygen--
takes in some randomness, and
it spits out a private key
and a public key for you.
And you can use those later.
Sign, on the other hand--
sign function used
to have the message
to sign in your private key,
and it would output a signature.
In ring signatures, you
sign with the message
you want to sign--
your private key
and then pick a list
of other people's public keys.
And this list can be
just a single one.
It can be 1,000.
You pick a bunch of other
people's public keys,
and you generate a signature.
And then verify, you
use the signature to--
take the signature in--
the message that's been signed,
and that list of pubkeys.
And it outputs a Boolean of,
yep, that signature worked,
or, no, it didn't but it
doesn't tell you which
of the public keys is signed.
So this is a really cool idea.
I think the initial
paper was How
to Leak a Secret, which was--
and then there's different
papers about different more
efficient ring signatures.
But this is a really
cool thing to use.
I think this could
be really cool
for a lot of different things.
If people had public keys
that they were associated with
and wrote them on their business
cards and stuff like I do--
you could then have
leaking information
that's more credible.
So instead of just
the newspaper saying,
sources close to the
matter said x, y, z,
or a top official at the
White House said this.
You could have it
being signed, and we've
got all these different White
House officials' public keys--
one of them signed this message.
So either there was
a key compromise,
and they all lost their keys,
which is, in practice, probably
more likely in that case, or
one of these people signed
this message, and I
know it's one of them,
but it doesn't reveal
anything about which
of the public keys--
so, that's pretty cool.
So you can verify it's from a
key in the array of public keys
but not which.
So let's put these together.
I can sign with x to
prove that v is 0.
I could also sign with x prime,
which I'm defining as x minus h
to prove that v is 1.
Well, what if I have
a ring signature where
I say I'm going to produce a
signature from both of these--
from one of these 2 public keys.
And that would prove
that v is either 0 or 1.
But it doesn't prove which.
Make sense?
So the idea is, I can make these
signatures that essentially
reveal what v is.
They indirectly reveal what v
is by saying there's no way I
could have made this
signature unless v was 0,
or unless v was 1
because you're--
you know that the h component--
v is the coefficient for h.
So you need to know that I don't
have an h component in there
if I'm going to make a
signature with respect to g.
And I can make any number
of different x primes
by subtracting
different amounts of h.
But a single
signature would just
reveal what v was,
which isn't useful.
But a ring signature, whereas
there's 2 different pubkeys--
one of them's x-- one of them's
x prime, we just subtract h.
And I'm going to
provide a ring signature
from one of these 2 pubkeys.
Now I've proven to you--
well, v is either 0 or 1--
it can't be both.
But it can't be 2.
It can't be 3.
It's got to be one
of those two values.
So does this make sense?
Questions on this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What does
unverified look like?
How does it verify that?
TADGE DRYJA: Oh, well,
the original scheme
is kind of complicated.
The one used in
confidential transactions
is Borromean ring signatures.
You do a bunch of
hash functions.
I don't know it.
I don't even really know it
well enough myself to really be
able to explain it in a minute.
But, basically, you
compute something
on all of the pubkeys,
and then verify
the signature on the
aggregate pubkey as a way
to think about it.
The signatures can--
the computing time
gets big with a
number of pubkeys.
So if you have millions of
pubkeys that could possibly
be signing--
the verification algorithm
gets really time-consuming.
So I can maybe go into ring
signatures another time.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I thought
the point of this
was to prove that
v is non-negative.
So right now, we're
just saying it's not--
it could be two values.
How does it help us
through the signs?
TADGE DRYJA: Well, neither
of these are any good.
So we've just proven--
we've done quite a bit more
than prove it's non-negative.
We've proved that it's
exactly 0 or exactly 1.
We might want more values.
So make a ring
signature from a million
different public keys
where the pub n is just
pub n minus 1 minus h.
And then I just proved that
v is somewhere in the range
from 0 to 99999.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What is computation
time for ring signatures
as the number of public keys?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, it goes up.
The best is linear, or, no,
there might be-- sorry--
there's probably sublinear now.
But this is not feasible.
[LAUGHS]
The traditional
ring signatures are
linear with the number of
public keys to be verified.
So if you did this--
well, all even then, you'd have
to throw, though, because--
you have to at least
throw the public key
into the verification function.
And so that means you need to
compute a million pubkeys--
throw it into that function.
It's going to take a long time.
So this is not
itself going to work.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Just Monero
uses ring signatures?
TADGE DRYJA: Yes, Monero
uses ring signatures
for a different reason.
Well, now they use it for
this kind of thing, too.
The Monero ring
signature was initially
used for not hiding
the amounts but hiding
which outputs were being spent.
So in Bitcoin, everyone should--
So in Bitcoin if you
have a transaction--
here's my input,
here's my output.
And the simplest one is just--
this points to tx5 or something,
and then my output is address--
and it's address b,
and it's got 7 coins.
Everyone can see
what you're spending.
The idea in Monero is, I
don't point to an input--
I just provide a signature.
And it's up to you to figure
out where that signature's from.
So I provide a signature
and a list of pubkeys--
pub a-- pub b.
So the smallest would be 2.
And then I provide a key--
key in a number.
So the idea is instead of
thinking of it as outputs,
you think pubkeys have
associated values.
You don't look at the
transactions themselves.
This is key c.
And there previously have been--
pubkey a and pubkey b have had
values--
7 coins sent to them.
And I can now say,
look, I'm going
to provide a ring signature from
either pubkey a or pubkey b.
And I'm not going
to tell you which,
but you can see that both
pubkey a and pubkey b have
received 7 coins in the past.
I want to send 7
coins over here.
I'm going to prove that
I own one of those two.
And then you can validate
that the transaction's valid.
And then if later, you see
another transaction with a ring
signature from pub a--
pub b-- also sending
to the key d--
7 coins.
Now, I can delete
pub a and pub b.
I don't know which, this--
so in transaction 1, I don't
know whether a or b was spent,
but one of those two was.
And then in transaction 2,
I don't know whether a or b
are spent-- one of them was.
But anyway, they've
both been spent now.
And so I can delete
them from my storage.
But the ring
signature's in Monero
were used to obscure the
transaction graph itself--
where you can see that there's
a bunch of different keys
that have money
associated with them.
And I'm going to
provide a signature
that I own one of them,
but I don't tell you which.
And now they also do
confidential transactions
to obscure the outputs using
ring signatures as well.
So I don't-- well,
it's interesting.
I haven't looked
at it that closely.
So I know that's the basic idea.
But there's a lot of
subtle details involved
in how that works, and I'm
not super familiar with that.
So I can finish up.
So the way to make
this practical
is, let's say you have a
ring signature for each bit,
so you're going to have to
have a different signature
for each bit in your value.
So the pubkey x0--
well, I'm going to have
a ring signature where I
prove that it's either 0 or 1.
And here I'm going to
prove it's either a 0 or 2.
Here I'm going to prove
it's either 0 or 4.
And so if I have
32 signatures, I
can now prove a 32-bit number.
Each of those
individual signatures
only has 2 public keys
associated with it.
So that's now more feasible.
There's a total of 32
public keys, 32 signatures--
not the end of the world--
still kind of ugly.
And then there's
optimizations where
since these pubkeys are all
the same, the 0 value for that
bit--
we can squish them
together and stuff
to make it a little bit smaller.
So you have a signature
per bit of your output.
If your values are not
too big-- this works.
We're going to
limit it to 32-bits.
So from 0 to 4 billion.
Now you can prove that each
bit was either a 0 or 1,
essentially, without revealing
whether it was a 0 or 1.
And then it's a couple
of kilobytes per output.
So it's a little bit annoying.
It used to be 8 bytes.
You said, hey,
I've got 37 points.
Also, these 8 bytes are very
sparse in that they rarely
exceed 4 bytes.
So you can compact
it down on disk.
So this is a little--
scalability-wise, it's an issue.
You're now going from what used
to be 8 bytes is now a couple
kilobytes.
I think they've got it
down to 2 kilobytes.
But still, that's 2 kilobytes.
And it takes a bit more
CPU time to verify.
Because now, instead of
verifying one signature
to see that the coins are
moving to the right place,
you're verifying
30-plus signatures
for every input and output.
Also, the real problem
is it's not really
compatible with Bitcoin--
this would be a really
tricky fork to implement.
How do you implement this
such that the old software
on the network is OK
with these transactions
where they're expecting a
transaction that has a value?
Here's how many coins
are being moved.
If you say, no, I'm not
going to tell you anymore.
Well, old software doesn't
know how to deal with this
and by default, will
reject these transactions.
So there's ways to do it that
doesn't break compatibility,
but they're pretty ugly.
One of the ways is
to say, OK, from now
on, all these transactions--
all output values have to be 0.
So the old software
will still work,
but it will be pretty
confused and say,
I see all these values.
I see thousands of transactions.
No one seems to be
sending anyone any money.
So they seem to be pointless.
And then there's
this hidden value
that's in a different
data structure that would
look something like segwit.
And segwit was a little bit
ugly-- this would be real ugly.
Those are the trade-offs
we're dealing with here--
tricky fork.
But you get this.
This is what you get when you
use confidential transactions.
You got it, right?
We have private,
unlinkable amounts
where the network can verify--
OK, let me verify that w
plus x equals y plus z--
that's the easy part.
Now, let me verify for every
individual w, x, y, and z
that it is within the
range of 0 to 6223222232--
02 to the 32--
it's a tongue-twister--
by verifying
all these separate
ring signatures
for each bit of the amount.
But you can do it, right?
You can verify-- input
amounts equal output amounts.
All these input amounts
and output amounts
are normal looking
numbers that aren't
too big that aren't
right up near the modulos
to wrap around.
And it works-- it's
just big and slow--
we're trying to
make that faster.
So probably not going to go--
if you're interested in this,
though, there's a lot of
research about this kind
of thing right now.
It's really cool getting in
the crazy, interesting math.
So there's bulletproofs, which
was Benedict's at Stanford.
He wrote up-- I mean, a
bunch of people wrote it,
but I think it was
sort of his idea,
or his thing working
with other people, too.
That's more efficient
range proofs.
I do not know how
bulletproofs work.
I tried to read the paper
and got two pages in,
and I don't know.
[LAUGHS] But I'm sure
I could figure it out--
it would just take
me a long time.
And then the Borromean
ring signatures--
the more efficient
ring signatures
that can compact a lot of
data so that you're not--
so you get it down
to two kilobytes
for these range proofs in
confidential transactions.
And then I may try
to give a class
about this in a week or two--
MimbleWimble.
The idea is that when all of
the transactions in the network
are like this and that have
confidential inputs and outputs
amounts, the transactions
can be canceled out
in an interesting way.
Because the output
amounts are unique.
They have these
blinding factors.
They have these range proofs.
And so if you're in a block--
so just a hint
about MimbleWimble--
the idea is if you have
a transaction and amounts
are all obscured.
But a is being consumed,
b is being consumed,
c is being created,
d is being created.
These are amounts.
And then I see
later in the block
there is another transaction
which spends d coins
and sends to e coins.
I don't have to verify that
a plus b equal c plus d.
And d equals e kind of thing--
I can just cross these out.
And I can verify on
a block-level instead
of a transaction-level that
the input amounts and output
amounts all matched up because
I don't know what d is.
But, anyway, it was
on an output side
and on an input side
within the same block.
So, anyway, it's gone.
It's being added to and
subtracted in this block.
So I can do that.
And I can do that
over multiple blocks.
And I can basically keep
a tally of how many coins
are in the system and
cancel things out.
So that lets you do some
really cool things where
you can skip a lot
of verification
at no loss of security.
So that's the idea of
a MimbleWimble, which
is really a fun paper because it
was written by Lord Voldemort.
Someone posted a
Pastebin link on IRC.
And who knows who wrote this--
Lord Voldemort.
Except it was Lord Voldemort--
the French word
for Lord Voldemort.
So when they translated
Harry Potter into French,
they changed the
names around, I guess,
and it was the French
equivalent of Lord Voldemort.
And so now there's a bunch of
people programming MimbleWimble
and implementing it.
And they all use Harry Potter--
not all of them,
but a lot of them
use Harry Potter
names on GitHub.
So it's kind of funny.
It's also really funny that
it was one of the most--
I would say, the most--
whoa, kind of paper of 2016 now.
And so it's of an
interesting indicator
of the space we're working in
that you've got IBM and all
these big companies, and they're
working on blockchain research,
and, honestly, not a
ton of awesome stuff,
whereas like, whoa,
MimbleWimble, OK,
Lord Voldemort--
he really showed everyone.
[LAUGHS] So it's fun that it's
still a very out-there hackery
system.
So that's-- hopefully, most
people got most of the idea.
It's a little bit fast.
It sort of explained all the
Pedersen commitments and range
proofs and everything
in a little bit of time.
But I think you got the idea.
And if you're interested
in it, there's
a lot of current
research on this
and people implementing it.
And there's a lot of cool
things you can do with it, so.